of duda has just started um if duda wins
that game he's going to be ready for his
very first meltdown champions chess tour
final liam le needs at least a draw and
he has to win either this game or the
next one
to take it to tie breaks
we will jump into that game when this
one finishes
but could it be a long game still yup it
could be still but uh with this last
move it's looking like maybe ding has
found a way to just uh eliminate another
couple of pawns
the more pawns that disappear the less
likely it becomes that we'll be uh with
this game for too long so now i'm
expecting black's rook to give a check
you always want to drive your opponent's
king back to passivity white's king was
nicely placed on third rank drive it
away so that check was important and now
black defends his own pawn and we might
see the end of this game any moment yeah
there are repeating nothing else to do
black defends the pawn gives a check
three-fold repetition it's a draw
both of them shaking their heads they
look like magnus is going to take a look
at that game